so you think you know something about
video games do you well if you're
looking to test your video game trivia
or if you just want to learn some
interesting facts about the video game
industry
welcome to truth or fail a video game
edition very easy to play I'm going to
give you two supposed facts about video
games
only one of them will be true it's up to
you to guess which one is the correct
fact or else you will as the title
suggests fail and so without further ado
round one originally called Jumpman
Nintendo's mascot Mario was named after
his creator shanira Miyamoto's apartment
land Lord who was obviously also called
Mario or fat number two at the time of
Mario's conception graphical limitations
meant that they couldn't animate hair
which is why he has a red hat